[Music]
hello everyone how you doing my name is
Pete also known as now though here to
give you guys another iron Lords podcast
first look now the game we were looking
at to today is the streets of rogue now
streets of rogue is a 8-bits kind of
adventure type game a very similar to
enter the gungeon or games similar to
that where you are a character and then
you go through level by level to
complete those levels and get more money
to improve your characters now from the
things that I saw from this game it it
was very unique because you started the
game out as a character that had nothing
and you ended up completing the tutorial
missions so you can kind of understand
how you end up going through the system
so you can end up learning how to shoot
a weapon or in this case for a rock or
you can end up learning how to open up
doors hack computers you have all these
different options in the game where
allows you to give more versatility on
what you're doing now as for the
gameplay it was fun it was good now for
myself I kind of started getting a
little bored over time with it
but that's because these types of games
for me aren't usually enjoyable but what
I found with this particular game was
that it had a lot of different features
now the reason why you can come back and
play this game over and over and over
again and have this huge replayability
of the game is the levels are all from
what I saw different they're all
randomly generated they all look
different they all work differently you
can have multiple cops on that on that
screen or not now with the game itself
the when you go into
when you're about to go into the the
world if you will or go on a mission you
end up having the option of picking your
character you can pick a regular regular
guy you can pick a soldier a doctor and
each one ends up giving different type
of starting weapons which allows you to
kind of go through the level differently
now you even have a hacker that allows
you to hack the computers now from what
this game feels like to me it feels like
one of those games is just a fun time
sink type game now the game itself you
ended up starting with with I started as
the as one of the plain regular
characters and you start with nothing
and I actually found it really hard to
play as a character and I would end up
going to trash cans to end up getting
different types of money or items or
weapons or food for your health and and
things like that and the once I started
understanding that you can do that to
kind of start getting some items then it
started actually working out pretty well
so after you go through learning kind of
the basics you end up starting to go on
the missions which a lot which you end
up going and doing different things on
now the Michigan that I ended up going
on one of them was to assassinating a
guy blow up a generator and try to
haggle with some dude and it took me a
little bit of time to figure out how to
do that effectively because they had
security cameras turrets and they're the
police walking around so you ended up
having to kind of look at the game take
a second and go okay well what can I do
to cause something to happen so I
actually learned if I if I take the
baseball bat that I found from the
garbage can smash a window and then the
one of the guys were run out I would end
up being able to fight one of the guys
and not three of them so you end up
starting to learn those types of
strategies but some of them had guns
which they like we're able to like wrap
and shoot you and and push you away from
them so if you're running Hannibal the
baseball bat you really didn't
much other than throwing a rock now
after time I kind of started realizing
how to play the game and you after I
learned that I could draw people away
kill them one by one
going back it ended up working out
pretty well and I thought it was pretty
good so after after playing it for you
know about 15-20 minutes I kind of got
the groove and I kind of started playing
and the game felt very very like level
very like what is this what's the new
thing they're gonna give me what's a new
difficulty level they're gonna give me
and then I ended up starting to look
around more in your base of operations
and you realize that they had mutaters
which allow you to modify the way that
each thing plays as and then you also
had the option of what it's called the
the coop that's what I'm saying the game
is a co-op option which I don't know
anybody else with the game so I couldn't
really do but you got a two-player co-op
3 or 4 player and an online option which
would connect somebody to your steam
account now that is a really interesting
way to make the game more relaxed
because you could essentially like mess
with your friends who all playing
because like I I learned that if you if
you hit a generator and you stand by it
it blows up pretty much almost 1 shot so
you taste that like 90 percent of your
health and it's gonna make the game a
little bit more fun to you know play
with your friends and have some fun with
it so it was pretty good now the the
graphics of the game is essentially an
8-bit game like the pixelated game and a
lot of these games that I've been
reviewing lately have all been 8-bit
pixelation type games and it's it's very
interesting to see that this is just
another one and how it kind of
intertwines it because I think that they
can they can improve the look of it but
at the same time it had these little
twists and turns on a debt that made it
pretty pretty pretty ok to play pretty
fun to play I guess you could say
but after like I said after I went
through the first couple of boards I was
just like okay what's the next one and
like I said before you have those other
characters to kind of you know make them
a little little different so I like to
thank tinybuild for giving us this
review code I would really appreciate
you know more from tinybuild because
they they produce some amazing stuff and
I really enjoy do playing their games
and I love seeing where they're coming
out from so I would like to say thank
you everyone for checking us out and
iron loyd podcast is on on Sundays you
know check out Twitter thank you again
this is astounding once again and thank
you everybody and have a great night
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you